cs229
lecture 18. the topic for today we'll be
continuing our study of
unsupervised learning so the topics
today is
we're going to wrap up factor analysis
we mostly finished up
factor analysis last time except we just
stopped at the end where we finished the
derivation and didn't really have
have time to kind of ah answer some of
the pending questions and really get a
good feel for factor analysis
it almost felt like you know monstrous
looking expressions and
that's it but let's let's uh kind of
quickly revisit factor analysis to
to get some better understanding of
what's happening under the covers it's a
lot easier than it looks
and then the plan is to finish up
principal components analysis and maybe
start ica
independent components analysis i'm not
sure how much time we'll have for this
but hopefully we'll at least start this
and if possible finish it right so
a quick recap of the last lecture the
last lecture
um one one big proof that we covered was
the convergence of the expectation
maximization algorithm
and the proof was pretty simple it was
uh we
we wanted to show that um the em
algorithm
is guaranteed to increase the likelihood
of our
uh of of um of the observed data
in every step in every iteration right
and the way we went about doing that is
to show that
the likelihood at theta of t t plus 1
we want to show that it is greater than
the likelihood at
the previous theta of t
and the way we went about doing that
just is to show that the likelihood is
greater than the elbow you know jensen's
inequality tells us that
the elbow um for the same
at the same parameter uh value the elbow
for any value of t any value of q will
always be lesser than equal to that's
jensen's inequality
and then we um we saw what happened when
we switched from theta t plus one to
theta t and we
and this basically was the m step at
time step t so at the m step of time
step t we optimized theta
to obtain theta t plus one such that the
elbow was maximized
so theta t plus one is the maximizer of
this of
uh of of the elbow at q t so therefore
at theta t the elbow value will always
be uh lower
and then we saw from the corollary of
jensen's inequality that l
uh um that the elbow at uh at theta t
and q t is equal to
um the likelihood at um at theta t
right so it was three simple steps and
we we also uh kind of
saw the uh pictorial intuition
for intuition for this so at theta t
let us call this spanish not good
yeah so this is elbow
of q t
theta t right
if this is theta t where it is tight at
the likelihood so this is just l theta
and this is the elbow where at theta t
it is tight and then we maximize it
and we get theta t plus one
and we construct a new elbow that is
tight at theta l t
plus one so this elbow is
this and this elbow is this
right and and and so we got that l
of um theta t plus one
was was less than the
the ah um
l the likelihood of theta t is less than
likelihood of uh theta t
plus one right so that was the em proof
and then we moved on to factor analysis
where in factor analysis
we we first we were interested in the
case where
we want to model x's that live in a d
dimensional space
but we have n number of x's where n
is much smaller than d right and in
these cases ah we saw that
performing modeling it as a simple
gaussian will give us singular
covariance matrices
and therefore we instead what we ah what
we want to do
is to have a latent variable
corresponding to z
that lives in a lower dimensional space
and
have a matrix l from which the low
dimensional space is mapped up to a high
dimension
a d dimensional space and there is some
extra noise added
in the d dimensional space right and so
the ah
so the model was defined like this z
comes from
a lower a low dimensional gaussian which
has this k dimensions
so in in this problem k
is less than d
but k is less is greater than n right
so this is the assumption we are
operating where
n is much smaller than d ah but k is
also smaller than d but k is bigger than
n that's that's the
setting we are working in
hold on did i flip it so we want
k should be less than d but
d is much bigger than n but we want n to
be
greater than k yeah that's better right
so we want um
so z lives in a k dimensional uh
subspace
and it's it's normally distributed with
mean zero and identity covariance
and then x given z we assume
is generated in this way where mu l
and psi are parameters right so mu is
ah is like an offset for for in the x
dimensional space
so once we map map z
to high dimensional space it will still
be in mean 0
right so this is like an offset that we
add and
psi is some kind of an extra covariance
an extra diagonal matrix where each
dimension
in the d-dimensional space has an
independent noise that's added
right so at first these these might seem
pretty
arbitrary choices however if we kind of
visualize what's happening ah basically
what we have is
uh this this process can be visualized
like this
right so from this we see that
x minus mu is distributed according to
mean lz and some noise
psi so we can think of the set of z's
the set of
latent latent variables that we have
imagine we have
you know a design matrix of these z's
right just like in linear regression
so each z i is one example we have n
such examples
which of of k dimension and then
suppose we have you know
l one right consider l one to be like
theta
right so we have this this theta um
which is like you know a parameter and
when we
when we multiply this this design matrix
by theta we get
one set of column one column over here
right so you can think of this as d
independent linear regression problems
right so l is d by k and k and the
k k matches the dimension of the design
matrix
so think of this as the design matrix
design matrix and think of this as
d theta vectors
and think of this as d
label vectors
right so what is happening is ah for
each dimension in which x lives
we associate a parameter vector that's
one way to think of it
we associate a parameter vector and we
get
a noisy observation which is x x minus
ah
one column of x minus mu
right and and we have so so this this um
in linear regression we had a design
matrix
one parameter vector which
we try to fit to one column vector of ys
so this was y this was theta
and this was x but here you know the
terminology is different
we have a z design matrix and d
different parameter vectors you know d
different
and for each vector we have you know a
ah different label right so you can
think of this as d different linear
regressions happening simultaneously
any questions any questions here right
yes questions
yeah so every single exactly so every
single dimension in the d-dimensional
space
you can think of you can think of the
column corresponding to every single
dimension in the larger space corresp
you know
is like a label vector for that
linear regression
we're going to come to projections soon
yeah so so for now you know this is the
setting we're operating
and we subtract subtract x minus mu if
you can think of
mu as being the bias term
right so bias term you can add a you
know
each component of mu you can think of it
as
a biased term you are adding to each of
the d problems
and so if you subtract the mean from xs
you get this kind of uh
setting where this is this is this is
like a linear regression problem
and in linear regression problem we also
assumed that
y was equal to theta transpose
x plus epsilon when epsilon was
independent noise whereas over here we
are doing
x minus mu is equal to
is equal to z l
plus psi i i so this is one
um you can think of this as z i
and this is the first uh first row
so this is like a zi transpose l1
plus psi ii where this is the diagonal
matrix
that that we are adding right so this is
this this model is basically trying to
represent
d different linear regression models in
in vectorized notation where all of them
are are written in this kind of a matrix
matrix matrix notation
whereas previously we had this matrix
vector vector notation right
that's all that's happening here and
from this we
uh constructed the e step and the m step
right so the e step was pretty
straightforward
so q i was this uh so q i we said we set
it to be the posterior distribution
at the current values of
of mu l and psi and
this notation is pretty straight forward
it is just the conditional
of the gaussian we have seen this kind
of notation in
gaussian processes as well so for every
i
for every example we said q i to be a
normal distribution that has this mean
and this covariance and these are just
if you remember this this
comes from the surf complement and this
ah follows uh
the the uh uh notation where you know uh
you consider so much to be like the z
value
of of uh the uh x variable where you
subtract the mean divided by the
variance and then you
this this also has like the correlation
uh coefficient embedded in this
and then you multiply it by uh
multiplied by l transpose right so this
this this is just like
uh transforming uh in the case of
in the case of multivariate gaussians
and this is the sure complement from
which we get the covariance of
z given i so the goal here was
we calculated z i given
x i and that's that's that's uh that's q
i
right and from this we come up with the
m step so in the e step we always
estimate the latent variables and in the
m step we re-estimate the parameters
right that's that's going to be common
for any model including including a
gaussian gaussian mixture model and
factor analysis
so in the e step we estimated the latent
variables zi
and in the m step we re-estimate the
parameters
where l mu and psi are the parameters
so l we had this monstrous looking
expression
mu was just the mean of the excise that
should be intuitive
right uh because uh we're just what we
are doing is
is is uh transforming z via the l and
adding some mu
so lz has mean zero so
uh obviously the the uh
the maximum likelihood estimate of mu
will just be the mean of x's
and in fact that will not change from
iteration to iteration
right so that's just going to be mu so
you calculate it once and
in the next m step you can just reuse it
there's there's nothing that changes
here
and this psi i i was this you know
even horrible looking you know
expression worse than the l
uh uh expression for the l and
and uh and that's where we stopped uh
last lecture however even though these
look pretty scary
we can actually kind of dissect this a
little more and
and get a better understanding of what's
happening right so first of all
let's start with the l
right so to to ah to make this
understanding easier i will introduce
some new notation
right so
mu of mu z i
given x i right so mu of z i given x i
is the mean of the posterior
distribution
that we obtained in the in the e step
right it's a gaussian that is
concentrated at mu
so you can think of this as loosely
speaking let's let's call this kind of
z hat i right so it's it's our best
best guess of what z is
given our knowledge about xs right so so
this is our best estimate of
of zi right does that make sense this is
just our best
best best guess or best estimate about z
i
given what we know about x so that is
one notation
and now
x i minus mu
ah let's let's um
and we also have this term
l mu
z i given x i so now
l mu l times mu of z i given x i
is equal to basically l times
z hat i right we just defined ah
we saw that mu of z i given x i v we can
think of this as our best estimate of z
when l times z i
we see that you know l times z i
is our best estimate of x minus mu
right so l times z i think of this as
our
best estimate of
of x i minus mu
and therefore we will call this
x hat i minus mu
right so l of mu z i given x i
is just l of z z hat i and that's the
same as
x hat i minus mu
right now once we
we ah so what what what do what do we
what can we think of this as so think of
l z hat i to be the reconstruction of
x right so z hat i
is our best guess of what z is given x
is
and then l times v hat uh x i is what
you know is is now we are going from z
back to x so
you can think of l z hat i plus mu to be
the reconstruction of x
right so over here plug in z hat x i
here
multiplied by l and we get x hat minus
mu
right so this is like the reconstruction
of x i
so that
expression can now be written as l
is equal to
sum over i equals 1 to n x i minus mu
so x i minus mu lets lets ah you know
think of it as as y i
you know following the linear regression
example and
mu
mu of of z i
so mu of z i let's uh let's call this
so mu of z i is basically this entire
vector z
so mu of z i is our estimate of of
the z vector so let us just so i am just
going to call it
capital z i
transpose
and here again this this basically is is
can think of it as z z z
transpose z
plus you know some some ah some
covariance
inverse or if if we
take the transpose we get
no we don't need the function so this is
basically like
um you can think of this as you know l
transpose
is equal to this comes here
z transpose z plus you know
something inverse
z transpose y right so
basically we are we are doing some kind
of a regularized linear regression
right that's what's happening in the l
expression over there right
so we have we make our best guesses
about z
we have x's that are given to us
and using those best best guesses for z
we may we
update our l and for that we are just
solving
d different linear regressions in
parallel
right so that's that's that's l
now what about psi right so psi
is also this you know scary looking
expression
and we're going to use you know the same
terminologies
uh in there as well so
what we end up getting there is
something like
you can
you can think of this as you know i
equals one to n
x i x i transpose
and now in place of of mu of
z i
so over here let's call
l mu to be x hat so that's
that is minus x i
know x hat i transpose
and then l mu is again x hat i minus
x hat i x i transpose
minus if we expand the
the uh the matrix on the other side we
get
plus l mu you know think of it as x hat
i
x hat i and the l comes from the other
side
x hat i transpose
plus l sigma
z i given x i
l transpose right and now this can be
written as
equals 1 to n x i
minus x hat i
x i minus x hat i
transpose plus l times
z i given x i
l transpose right so
this if you if you if ah if you
recognize what we are doing
is we are taking the the correct label
minus our estimate of the correct label
right and and
this is is is therefore similar to
estimating
the noise in linear regression right so
in linear regression if
y equals theta transpose x plus
epsilon the way to estimate epsilon from
your data
is to first find out theta hat and then
do one over n
i equals 1 to n y i
minus theta hat transpose
x i i square right so this is
this is this is the way we estimated
estimate epsilon in
in linear regression if we need to and
similarly you know we are we are
estimating this psi
which is the noise that's getting added
to to ah
excise right and this
because of the notation turns out to be
a full matrix
however we are we are interested in each
of the d
examples independently and therefore
this this matrix that we obtain we are
just going to take
the ith element to be
iit element of this this is basically
like saying we do not care
about the covariance of the noise
between
one linear regression problem and
another regression linear regression
problem
right so we are just ignoring the off
diagonal elements here
right this makes sense any questions
so the l matrix is what we have what we
what we have in the
in the update that that's or was it a
different question
so x hat you can you can think of x hat
as so
if we so so you can think of you know um
you can think of of uh factor analysis
as this you are given the y labels
for different problems right and by just
given
by just having the y labels you want to
construct both
the covariates as well as the parameters
right it's a really hard problem right
you're given xs and you want to estimate
both z's and
else l's are the parameters that we
that that's part of the model right
and z i's are the latent variables that
specific to each each example
right so our goal is to not only
estimate what our design matrix was but
also estimate what the parameters was by
just having the labels
which which which sounds you know kind
of impossible
but given these these modeling
assumptions that
these come from from uh normally
come from a normal distribution and that
they follow this kind of a linear
relation
you can apply em algorithm to this and
you can estimate it
was that there was another question
so you can think of think of a factor
analysis
as this problem where you are given just
the labels
for d different problems right
and you are assuming a linear modeling
of some hidden covariates we don't know
the design matrix
we don't know the parameters and we are
estimating both the design matrix
and the set of parameters given just the
labels
right it sounds of it it's kind of
magical here you're just given labels
and you're estimating both what
your x's were as well as the parameters
with only the assumption
that your your your with the only
assumption that the inputs
are distributed according to some kind
of a normal distribution with mean
right and mu here just ends up being the
the bias term
you know one per one per ah one per
linear regression problem
right yeah so this looks kind of
monstrous but
if you if you think of each of these l
mu
to be like x hat
right then you can visualize this as you
know
estimating just the the reconstruction
noise
between x and x hat and and we are only
interested in the diagonal elements here
right so that wraps up our coverage of
factor analysis oh and uh
i think there was also one question
which uh a student asked by doing all of
this how did we actually
go about solving the the singularity
problem where you know
so if you remember
we briefly wrote this
notation that
for factor analysis you know
log p of x or the marginal likelihood
actually had this closed form expression
where it turns out to be
or x happens to be
a normal with
mean mu and covariance
l l transpose plus psi
right so the covariance matrix estimated
for the
marginal of x is therefore this ll
transpose which is a low rank matrix
plus a diagonal matrix and because we
are adding a diagonal matrix
to this low rank matrix we are
guaranteed that this
is no longer singular
right all right
so let us move on ah so this this
basically wraps up
factor analysis and now we will start
principal components analysis
pca
so in factor analysis our goal was to
to model x s as something that
approximately lies in a low dimensional
space
right so for every x we had a
corresponding z
and z lived in a lower dimensional space
and the relation between x and z
was was uh what you call as affine
affine is another word for linear plus
some offset
right so l defined l
gives us from z to the centered x and
then you add some kind of an offset
so x and z are related by what's also
called an affine relationship
right so and
we had to go through this em algorithm
because we were
we were modeling it with this with the
assumption that d was much larger than n
right p c a is another approach
to where you are given
x i's i
equals 1 to n and
x i is
in d and now
here we no longer
we no longer assume that d is much
larger than n
we we are back into the usual regime
where we have you know
generally have more number of much more
number of data points
than the dimensions of the space
and now we want to
we want to find out if our data
actually lives in a low dimensional
space right so ah
for example if you know here is one
example
so if this is a data set where we are we
are plotting so this is x one and x two
so if you have a data set where you are
plotting
the example in the nodes is supposing
you are uh
you fly helicopters or you fly you know
toy helicopters whatever
and for every for every such
you know pilot you have a skill level
and the level they enjoy flying
the helicopter right and if you are
trying to to
if you look at the scatter plot of skill
versus enjoyment
know you wouldn't be surprised if you
see some kind of a linear relationship
between them
and it's more or less because you know
people who enjoy
flying helicopters are likely to be you
know good at it and vice versa right so
even though you have two different
variables they are kind of
you know reading off this
underlying you know common
common trait of the pilot you can call
it you know piloting karma or whatever
and you know and and therefore these two
are are pretty correlated
and now um your data may therefore have
um if your is
in general so you know if you have any
examples
and d features right so some of your
features may be kind of correlated so if
you if you have
um if this is a data set about
pilots and one of the features is you
know their skill level
and another feature is you know the
level of enjoyment they report flying
helicopters right
even though this looks as a d
dimensional space
because you know some or many of your
features may kind of actually level in a
lower dimensional space
your entire d dimensional space can
probably
be represented in a lower dimensional
space
which is k right by
ah by this i don't mean element wise
similar i i uh we are just thinking of
representing this high dimension high
dimensional data
in a low dimensional space this question
yeah so the question is uh why isn't
this supervised learning
where you know you can think of one of
them uh you can take
one of them to be why and and kind of
regress it from the others
you can do it as a supervised learning
problem but the
the problem is in general quite hard
in the sense uh your you don't know
upfront which label which which of these
features you want to choose as your y
label
you can try it with all of them you can
try you know a subset of them
it's not clear you know how to go about
actually uh solving this as a price
learning problem what if if d is 10 000
right are you going to perform 10 000
you know linear regressions
you could do that but you know pca is
much more efficient
you you uh you could uh uh do something
like that though this is uh pca as you
will see is much more straightforward
you don't have to
you know pose it as a supervised
learning and and learn it etc so it's a
pc is more straightforward
right so in in pca our goal is to
therefore
ah find subspaces of our data or
find a subspace in our input space where
the data kind of lives
right so
in pca the first thing we do
is to
center our data and scale it to have
variance one what we mean is the first
step in pca
is to
you know standardize your data set
which means you want to set x
j i to be
x j i minus
mu j divided by sigma j
where mu j is the mean of the jth column
and sigma j is the is the standard
deviation of the jth column
right so first thing is independently
kind of
center each column and
scale each column so that the column has
variance one
so that is the first thing where mu j is
one over n y equals
one through n x j i
and sigma j square is
one over n
i equals one to n x j
i minus mu j square
right so the first thing is we want to
standardize our data set to have mean 0
and standard deviation 1.
and the reason we we want to do this is
um
it may so happen that the units in which
your your
data is represented can be very
different so ah
for example ah if you are representing
for example the height and weight of a
person in a data set where each row
corresponds to a person
you know height may be you know you
never know the weight may be represented
in
in kilograms but height may be
represented in millimeters
right so the the values in the height
column will generally be much much
bigger than values in the in the weight
column for example
right so the first thing you want to do
is to kind of become agnostic to the
units in which your data is represented
and for that we just standardize each of
the column independently
and once we do that
the way we want to find the the
underlying subspace is like this
so
right so let us assume this is x 1
x d and if your if
your data is
right so we could try to
find a subspace here
and project all our points onto the
subspace
so this is one possible projection
so each of the each of the crosses
were the x's that lived in the high
dimensional space
right
right so this is one way to ah you know
this is one possible
low dimensional subspace on to which we
are projecting
all the individual data elements onto
the low dimensional subspace
right and you know another possible
subspace
is x one
x d and
trying to draw the same things here now
what if
instead we chose this to be our subspace
right
if ah
well there is one technical error in
what i did
the subspace must span through the
origin so instead let me just
redraw the axis so that it
yeah let's assume this is x t
right and its going through the origin
so instead we could we could also have
this to be the subspace and if we can
project
all the points onto our subspace
right if you remember projection means
to find
the closest point on the subspace
to our the point which you are trying to
project
okay so and and and the the natural
consequence of that is that
the the the uh the line connecting the
projection to the point will always be
perpendicular
to the subspace itself right so
we could have you know there are an
infinite number of subspaces that we can
come up with
right and we could either use you know
this is one possible subspace onto which
you are projecting
this is another possible subspace onto
which we are projecting but pca tells us
that the subspace on to which you want
to project your data
should be the one where the the
variance of the projected points is
maximized
what do we mean by that it means so if
you look at the
projected points in this example you
know they are kind of clustered
clustered within within ah within the
space and
if you calculate the sample covariance
it would be you know some some uh uh
it's it's of some value right however
with this we see that
the projected points are much more
spread out
right this is much bigger than this
right it is the same points
but different choice of subspace but the
the
variance of the projected points the
projected points in this case are much
more spread out compared to the
projected points here and pca tells us
or what pca does is
to find this low dimensional subspace
this k dimensional subspace of this d
dimensional space
where the projected points have maximum
variance
right so it is a variance maximizing
procedure where we find
a subspace such that the projected
points on the subspace have highest
variance
right and
the way we represent the subspace is
through these
unit length vectors
so the idea behind you know doing
something like this is that
we want to we want to retain as much of
variance
that is in the data to the extent
possible even after projecting it down
to a low dimensional space we don't want
to lose the variance we just want to
lose the number of dimensions where the
data lives we want to project onto a low
dimension a lower dimensional space
but we do not want to lose the variance
in our data we want to retain the
variance in the data
but lose just the dimensions that is the
idea with pca
right so
[Applause]
so suppose we are we are
suppose we represent the low dimensional
subspace with
unit vectors u so if
u you can think of u in
[Music]
rd to be unit length
right so if if u is represents you know
a basis of the subspace of unit length
on to which we want to project
our data you might remember from one of
our earlier lectures
if u is is a basis vector
the projection of x onto the space
spanned by u will be
the projection matrix of u
projection matrix of u times x where x
is you know uh the
the point that you want to maximize
and so
so that would be the
that would be the projected point and
this you know the projection matrix of u
is basically u u transpose over
u transpose u of
x right that's just the projection
matrix of of um
rejection and we see that
um u transpose u is just 1
and so the projected point will be just
x i transpose
u right so this will be x i
x i transpose u
this is a scalar times u
now the ah what we what we want to do is
to find
u such that the
the variance of across these projected
points is maximum
right so ah if we have n examples
what we want to maximize is the for all
in examples
the norm of this this projected point so
the norm of the projected point
is basically the length from here to the
projected point
right the if we max
if we find u such that the sum of the
squares
of all the projected lengths is maximum
then effectively we would have performed
pca
so what we want to do is
find u
such that
one over n sum i equals one to n
the norm of the
prediction of u times x square
is maximized right and this is the same
as
one over n i equals one to n
x
x i transpose u so this is just a scalar
times u norm is maximized
so we want to maximize this
maximize this
or another u is equal to r max of this
right and this we see that it is some
scalar times
a unit length vector so the norm of
this whole thing is just one over n
i equals one to n
x i transpose u
square right so the norm
of a scalar times a unit length vector
so the norm of that is just the square
of the
the scalar itself right and this we can
now
write this as continue here
and that is equal to
u transpose
1 over n
i equals 1 to n x i
x i transpose u
right and because our x's
were centered
this thing has mean 0 and therefore this
entity over here
is the sample covariance matrix
right so you might remember this from
some optimization class you took
this u equals
arg max u of
u transpose sum matrix
u in this case this happens to be 1 over
n i equals 1 to n
x i x
i transpose right
does anybody know what the solution for
of of u is in for this problem
where u is a vector
so u in this case is identifying so so
if
if you solve this the solution u is
basically
the eigenvector corresponding to the
largest eigenvalue of this matrix
right and and that's uh that's that's ah
that's because
r max of u of
u transpose a u
will give you
eigen vector of
largest eigen value
of n
right and this analysis holds
where instead of u if you have um
where here we we just considered one u
one vector
but if you consider a whole basis of of
uh
basis vectors then nothing in this
argument changes
by performing this maximization you
would have recovered
uh where instead of a single u if you
had k
u vectors then by performing this
maximization where instead of one vector
you have
k u vectors you will have recovered the
top
k eigen vectors corresponding to the
largest eigen values
next question
so how we went from here to here yeah
so ah
so this step i am going to write it here
1 over n
i equals 1 to n
x i transpose
u square right and this is the same as 1
over n
so i am equals 1 to n
x i transpose u
x i transpose u it's just the square
and this we can write it as 1 over n
equals 1 to n
x i transpose u and this dot product we
just write it the other way and then we
get u
transpose x i
rather i should have done it the other
way so instead if you had swapped this
get i equals 1 to n
u transpose x i
x i transpose u right
and then you can take the u common out
of all the summation and that gives us
u transpose i 1 over n
plus 1 i equals 1 to n
x i x i transpose
u
so basically ah
by by following this variance maximizing
argument
where we want to maximize the sample
variance or
the the uh the projected points onto our
subspace
must be as far as possible from the
origin right
by following this variance maximizing
principle if we find
the basis u such that
the the projected variance is maximized
we will see that we will end up with an
eigenvalue problem
where we want to calculate the
eigenvectors of the sample covariance
value
matrix of xs right
so if x is our data
data matrix pca tells us that first
calculate
x transpose x right
x transpose x is basically this written
in in matrix notation
take x transpose x and calculate the
eigen vectors and eigen values or
calculate the spectrum of
of the x transpose x
and depending on the number of
subspaces that we want to retain
so x transpose x will give us a
collection of
lambda i u i so say lambda 1 u 1
lambda 2 u 2
until lambda d ud
right these are the d eigen vectors
eigen values and u's are the d and u's
are the d eigen vectors
and now what we want to do
is is ah if depending on
the amount of variance that we want to
retain a common practice
is to then choose as many lambdas
or as many pairs of eigenvectors
such that the
or a more more precise way to say it is
find
k such that
sum over i equals 1 through k
lambda k over some more
i equals 1 to d
sorry lambda i lambda
i this
is equal to you know some some kind of a
percentage say 95 percent or something
right and its its common to choose k in
pca
by first performing the eigen
decomposition of
x transpose x right and then
by you know sort your eigen values in
in some kind of a decreasing order in a
decreasing
order and then find k such that
the sum of the first k top k eigen
values
divided by the sum of all the eigen
values is some
you know a percentage of your choice and
by
choosing k to be you know 95 you can
effectively say that you've retained 95
of the variance in your data even though
you went down from
d dimensions down to k dimensions this
question
right so um
any questions in this the way we go
about doing it is to take x transpose x
take the eigen decomposition of ah x
transpose x
obtain the the eigen vectors of x
and then choose k such that
the sum of the top k eigen values
divided by the sum of all the eigen
values
is the fraction of variance that you
want to retain
so if you were to plot ah
let us say this is
k and this is
fraction of variance
you will generally see that
if this is d then you will generally see
that this goes down something like this
where
or rather this is d minus k which means
uh if if you were to prune out all the d
eigenvectors then you you will be having
zero
uh variance uh remaining but if you
prune zero you will hold uh you'll be
having all the variants remaining
and generally you know this remains flat
for quite a long time which means even
if you
prune a big fraction of your feature
space
you will still be having you know like
95 of your variance next question
yes so you in this case we showed it
we showed the the uh showed the
intuition using a single
single eigenvector but
effectively we just calculated the
largest eigen you know showed that the
largest eigen
eigenvector is is the one that minimizes
maximizes the variance if you project it
to one dimension
but if you want u to be larger then or
rather if you want k to be larger
you know this was k equals 1 if you want
k to be larger
then just do the the full eigen
decomposition
rather than just this optimization
because this just gives you the top
eigenvector
so instead do the full eigen
decomposition
and hold on to the you know top k
eigenvalue eigenvector pairs
right any questions in this so far
so for those of you who may be familiar
with singular value decomposition
what we performed here is also called
singular value decomposition
so svd
let me write it here
ok
maybe we covered this in one of the
earlier lectures but if you have a
matrix
x where x is
square and
symmetric
then x has
orthogonal eigen basis
eigen vectors and
real eigenvalues
right and if x
is positive semi definite then
then it is obviously square and
symmetric and if it's also psd
then eigen values
are positive all the eigen values are
positive
right now in this case
um we are using
x transpose x to be uh to be the matrix
on which we are
we are performing uh eigen decomposition
so it is x transpose x is guaranteed
to be square symmetric and positive semi
different
right now performing
eigen decomposition
on x transpose x
is the same as performing
singular value decomposition on x
right the way you go about doing
singular value decomposition on any
matrix x
in this case for to do singular value
decomposition your matrix need not be
psd
it need not be symmetric it need not
even be square
are given any matrix whatsoever the way
you perform singular value decomposition
on any matrix x
is to take x transpose x take the
eigenvectors of
x transpose x and the eigenvectors of x
transpose x
and the eigenvalues of x transpose x
will or the square root of the
eigenvalues will give you the singular
values of x
right so this is the same as performing
singular value decomposition on on
um on the x matrix which is you know
another way to think of the same thing
is to construct x transpose x and just
do eigen
eigen decomposition on x transpose x
any questions on on on pca
in homework we you will see so here we
we saw the variance maximizing argument
where if
where uh you know we want to find
a hyper plane where
if you take the
projections then the variance of the
projections so
this distance you know this distance
this distance you know
this is basically the you know the
the spread of the projected points is
maximized
in homework you should you will show
that this method
is equivalent to um or
or you will see another motivation where
if you were if you
if you rephrase the problem as finding a
subspace
where the the projected points
are as close as possible or as near as
possible to the original points
that is to minimizing this this distance
right so maximizing the the projected
variance
and minimizing the the residuals
are equivalent and in in your homework
you will show that if you phrase it as a
problem of minimizing the
the the uh residuals or minimizing or
improving the approximation of the
projected points to your original points
you will recover the same same solution
as maximizing the variance
like there are two different two
different ways to think of of pca find
find a subspace such that the
projections are as close as possible to
the original points that's
you know interpretation two that you
will do in the homework the
interpretation one that we
saw in the lecture is find a subspace
such that the projected points have
maximum variance
any questions on pca
ok great so let us move on to ica so
looks like we are making good progress
so we might be able to finish
ica today
so in ica
its ah somewhat different problem
from from um
the problems we see so far
and to perhaps to understand kind of the
the the
um the difference of icm
it might be useful to kind of kind of uh
place together the algorithms we've seen
so far so so far we have seen
let's see i can erase this one
so so far in unsupervised learning we
have seen four algorithms
right so the first one we saw was
k-means we started off with k-means
right and then after k means we studied
gaussian mixture models
right and after gaussian mixture models
we studied
factor analysis
right and and today ah just now we
studied pca
right so we studied four algorithms so
far and you can kind of classify them
in two different ways right so
these you can call clustering algorithms
and these you can call them you know
subspace algorithms
these were probabilistic
and these were non probabilistic
right so the probabilistic algorithms
we solved them using e m
expectation maximization whereas the non
probabilistic
problems in the non-probabilistic
approach there was no there is no
we didn't have to use em right and
loosely speaking
again this is a very loose uh ah
analogy you can think of clustering
problems
to be the counterpart of classification
problems from
supervised learning
right you can think of them as as a
classification problems they are not
where you are not given the
the uh the labels and you can think of
these subspace finding problems as the
the counterpart of regression problems
from supervised learning
and there you know
both pca and factor analysis
in in both of these we we recovered a
low dimensional subspace
where in factor analysis z's were the
subspace
z was the subspace
and in pca the way we recover the
subspace
is to construct the the
the matrix u where u
is the um
there are k different
uh columns each of dimension d
and these are the the the top k
eigen eigenvectors of
x transpose x right and then using this
u matrix
which is we can multiply
u x
transpose so u x transpose will give us
ah u x transpose will give us
k such
or it would be easier to just do it as u
transpose so
x u transpose will give us the the
projected points of x onto the lower
dimensional space
right you take the eigen basis and take
each example and
multiply it uh and just multiply it on
to u so that's like projecting it on to
you because they have unit
unit lengths and x u will give us the
subspace now
you might you might ask what's you know
what what's what else is different
between factor analysis and pca
the other difference in factor analysis
we assume d
was much bigger than n
but here we made no such assumption here
we in fact we assume that n will be
bigger than d
if we don't assume n is bigger than
then d then again you know this would
it might work uh if this would be the
this would be singular but yes so in
fact actually
in in pci you probably don't don't don't
need to make
end to be than d but but it's commonly
the case that n
is indeed bigger than d and
the other ah difference between the two
was
in in factor analysis we recovered
the matrix l right
and l the the parameter that we
recovered took us from z to x
took us from z to x whereas in pca we
recover
u u takes us from x
to z if you call z as the projected uh
projected points
right so so the the uh the recovered
parameters kind of
go in opposite direction between factor
analysis and
and pca the other difference between pci
and factor analysis was in pca
you can first perform pca
get the set of all eigenvectors and
eigen values
and then decide after the fact
what is the appropriate k for your
problem you can decide k
after you perform pca whereas in em
you need to decide k first and then run
em if you're not satisfied with it
you need to change your k to a different
value and rerun
a factor analysis all the way again
right whereas in pca
you first perform eigen the icon
decomposition and then you look at
what k will give you the best variance
retaining factor
this question
uh you so so the question is
uh is it reasonable to first do pca to
find k
and then go to factor analysis but then
what's the point of going to factor
analysis because you would have
you know recovered a lower dimensional
subspace anyways
right so these are these are
some some um some ways in which we can
classify what we have covered so far
and now we are going to start ica
independent component analysis
right and in the independent component
analysis is somewhat
different in nature from what we have
seen so far
so uh is there is there a benefit of
doing factor analysis
it it so happens that
so factor analysis uh
let's think uh there are benefits to
doing factor analysis
for example when d is is uh
much larger than then um
so this would also be
yeah pca pca uh uh
it worked but the problem with with uh
so so so here's the thing in pca
we are not explicitly modeling the noise
in the data right so there was no
probabilistic assumptions being
being made whereas with factor analysis
even though you choose
you know k to be some value it it
generally works
uh pretty well because it will end up
adjusting your
the psi matrix accordingly if if
k is different so it's quite
you can think of them as two different
kind of equivalent
approaches you know the differences are
what we discussed
uh you know in in some cases it makes
sense to use factor analysis some cases
make sense to us pca
but pca happens to be you know more
commonly used because it's easy to
implement you just perform
um eigen decomposition and you get it
whereas a factor analysis the
you know it it also provided us a good
good weight
good example to apply em so when we
applied em
in one case z's were discrete but here
we saw z's were continuous right so
it was you know um as as as
an example to understand em better
factor analysis
is is um helpful like you know from an
educational purpose
uh but pca is probably used much more
commonly in practice than factor
analysis
right
another thing about pca that we kind of
skipped over was
we just said do eigen decomposition on x
transpose x
but sometimes x transpose x can be you
know
really huge in terms of you know the
number of dimensions
and you know if you were to use numpy or
matlab and
you know do you know eigen decompose on
a large matrix then you know that may
that may just fail you may run out of
memory or something so
in fact when you when you run pca in
practice
a common a common technique to perform
eigen decomposition
is to use something called power
iteration
right so power iteration is is commonly
is one of the commonly used techniques
to perform icon decomposition on
large matrices so again this is this is
uh this is there's not going to be
something you'll be
going to be tested on but the idea of
power iteration is to start
with some u0 and
randomly initialized u0 anything that's
non-zero
right and from u0
calculate x transpose x times
0 call right so u
1 will be x transpose
x times u 0 divided by the norm of
x x transpose x
x transpose x times u 0
so basically take some randomly
initialized matrix a randomly
initialized vector
multiply it by the matrix whose
eigenvector you're interested to
calculate
and you get u1 then multiply
you know x transpose x transpose x times
u1 will give you u2
right and if you keep multiplying
the vector over and over again by the
same matrix
and after every multiplication if you
rescale it
to have unit length and if you repeat
this over and over
you will end up you will you will see
that you will the
the uh the vector that you will end up
in the vector that you converge will be
the largest eigen vector
right the the intuition there is um
um suppose ah
you know this is x1 and xd
now if you remember if you take a unit
sphere in your input space and multiply
it
by a positive definite matrix then
the outputs will be on will be on some
kind of an ellipse
right so if you were to uh take this
as as the as the input and you know
if this is u naught multiplied through
through x transpose x then you you may
get
this to be the point that got mapped to
so this would be
x transpose x times u naught
and then rescale it back to unit length
multiply it through x
and you will get this and then rescale
it back multiply it through x
and you'll get this and eventually you
will see that you you know this will
always converge
to the principal axis of the ellipse
which is the eigenvector
right so multiplying the same matrix the
matrix over and over
and then rescaling the the multiplied
vector back to unit length if you repeat
that over and over
no matter where you start you will
either
you know converge along this direction
or if you start here
you will end up converging along this
direction but that is going to be your
principle uh
eigenvector right and then one you know
you can then take
you know x transpose x subtract from it
uu transpose
you will get a matrix of one lower rank
and then perform the same
power iteration on this matrix
and you will recover the next largest
eigenvector and so on so in practice
usually you do something like this
when the number of dimension is large so
this is called power iteration
this is just a good detail to know if
you come across the word power iteration
basically what's happening is you know
take a take a vector and repeatedly keep
multiplying it
by the same matrix and rescaling the
length back to
length back to one anyways
ica
in ica
the the in ica the the
motivation is probably best seen through
this uh
cocktail party problem right in the
cocktail party problem
um assume there are
b speakers
you know people who are speaking and
there are
d microphones
right so there are d speakers and d
microphones
and the d microphones are placed in
different places
of of of different lens and they are
recording the d
speakers simultaneously right
and we will call
s
in r d to be
ah you know think of
s in r d to be one instantaneous
recording
of the of the speeches
that are happening at the sources right
and we also assume that
the the recordings in the d
microphones we will call it x
it is also r d and we assume that
x is equal to a times s
where a is commonly called as the mixing
matrix
right so s
j i is the
is the thing that the ith speaker
is pronouncing at the jth time
right and similarly
x i
j is the recording
in the
in the jth microphone at ith time
did i say the other way so j is the
speaker identity
maybe i told it the other way first time
and i is the time
and similarly j here is the microphone
identity
and i is the time
right so what is happening is we have
d different speakers
saying whatever they are saying
and d different microphones that's
recording them so we have speaker one
over here
speaker two over here right let's let's
uh just start with two
right and we have uh microphone one over
here
right and microphone 2 over here that's
recording what they're saying so this is
x1 x2 s1
s2 now these are kind of placed at you
know
arbitrary distances from the speakers
you assume there is no
lag in in recording and let's say
you know speaker one
let's assume this is the wave form of
what the speaker one is speaking
right and speaker two
and this is the wave form of what
speaker to speaking
right and this is time
right time is progressing this way and
if we take a point in time
and record a snapshot right this will
give us
s i so at time i
s i will be said
s i 1
[Music]
s i 2
right and this is in rd
here d equals 2 right
so the the ah
s i 1 is this height s i 2 is this
height
right and and this is the time so you
can think of
a snapshot in time to be one example
and the the kind of the amplitude of
what the speaker is speaking at that
time
to be the coordinate value at that
example
right and similarly we have you know
ah the two microphones
right so this is microphone one x
one x two and this microphone is
recording
some linear combination of the two right
right this is x one and this is
x two right similarly over here again
time is moving to the right
and at time i
right x i
is equal to
x i 1 comma x i 2
but here these are the values recorded
by the microphone at time i
we will assume that
we have the same number of microphones
as the number of speakers
and we are only observing these
x's and the problem now is
we are only given these x's
we are told the number of you know we
obviously know the number of microphones
we assume that there are the same number
of speakers
and by only having these d different
microphone recordings
we want to recover the original uh
original speed signal spoken by each
speaker
right that's that's the that's the
setting in which we want to uh
in which we are operating and the
and what that translates to essentially
is
we have
we make the assumption that x equals
a s which means x i equals a of s
i right
a is a square matrix because we have the
same number of speakers as the number of
microphones
and what we want to do is to
calculate w is equal to a inverse
which is called the unmixing matrix
right w equals a inverse is the unma
unmixing matrix where
we are where w
can take x right and return
s so the w matrix can separate the
speaker so this is also called
the source separation problem where we
are given x's
which are different different mixtures
of the sources and using just these
mixed sources
we want to construct this w matrix
it is called the unmixing matrix which
will recover back the original speech
and the the the assumption that we are
going to make we are going to make only
one assumption
the one assumption that we are going to
make is that s i's
are distributed
a car are independent in the sense each
ssj
is independent of the other sjs so the
speaker the assumptions we are going to
make are
so what are the assumptions we made so
far so you the first assumption
was number of speakers equals number of
microphones
right and the second assumption we we
made was that these two are
are associated with a linear
relation so s is equal to w
x right we made a linearity assumption
and
the third assumption that we are going
to make
which you know with just these two it's
impossible to recover
right we want we need to make one more
one more uh some more assumptions
the uh the assumption that uh that's
gonna help uh
us recover is that we're gonna assume
s j is independent of s k
where j is not equal to k
what that means is s j has some kind of
a probability distribution
and s k has you know belongs to another
probability distribution
and these two random variables are
independent
okay it what what that essentially means
is we are assuming
that what one speaker is saying is
independent of what the other speaker is
saying which may not be a valid
uh assumption in reality if two people
are having a conversation then
most likely only one of them is speaking
at a time etc
but for for you know um
in in it generally
turns out that this is this still
happens to be a reasonable assumption to
me
right so independence assumption
and we need to make one more assumption
that will allow us to solve this problem
the last assumption that we are going to
make is that s
j is not
gaussian
right so this is a non gaussian
assumption
right why why why do we need to make
this non gaussian assumption
lets lets ah see a few pictures and
hopefully that will
give some intuition
so
can we switch off
right so these are basically the the
slides we saw in the intro lecture
just
let's hope the the audio works so
so here we have uh we're considering the
case of d
equals 2 and these are the
uh versions that are recorded in in the
microphones the two microphones
and these are what the original speaker
said
right so
it's basically two speakers counting one
to ten one in english and the other in
spanish
and this is a recording from another
microphone
the audio is a little low
and once it's separated it sounds like
this can people at the back hear it
okay one two
three four five six seven
eight nine ten right and the uh
the other one once it's separated
right so all that was fed to this
algorithm
was these two uh mixed clips
and nothing else and by making certain
independence assumptions
and linearity assumptions the algorithm
was able
to recover these separated versions of
the two audio clips
right and to ah
to understand um these
these assumptions i made a few slides
that might
yeah so
let me open it in three
right so what we have here so
ah we assume that s i and sj must be
independent
and we also assume that each of the sjs
must not be gaussian so
the the first row all the three rows
correspond to gaussian distribution the
second row all the three correspond to
laplace distribution and a third all the
three correspond to logistic
distribution so if in the case of
gaussians
here x1 the the x-axis and the y-axis
represent two independent gaussians and
each point
in this cluster of points are points
that are sampled
from a joint gaussian distribution where
the the the two components are
independent so if we sample from
two independent gaussian distributions
uh uh assume both are
uh have mean zero uh variance one then
you will see that the points are
generally
the clustered points have this circular
formation
right and then we apply
some kind of a linear transform so the
first column corresponds to
you know one linear transform the second
column corresponds to another linear
transform
the linear transform is applied to the
points that were sampled here
right and we see that if uh
so the the first column corresponds to a
linear transform that was more or less
just a rotation
we see that the rotated version looks
exactly like the original version if
it's gaussian
right if it is some other
distribution some other kind of a linear
transform then it gets
some kind of an ellipse shape right
now instead of instead of gaussians
let's assume we have
we start with two independent laplace
distributions
right where the source one and source
two are sampled according to
independent laplace distributions we see
that the shape
taken by the product of two independent
laplace
has this kind of uh uh you know
it has this diamond shape
right and then if we you know apply
linear transformations we get you know
shapes that look like this
and similarly if you start with the
logistic two independent logistic
distributions
ah if when they are independent they
look like this and as you
you know apply transformations they take
different shapes
in ica we are starting with data
that look like this right
the recorded the microphone recordings
if you were to plot them
they look something like this and
given these uh when we start if if we
were to
start with uh data that looks like this
and we want to recover the original
untransformed data
with laplace and logistic we see that we
can make a good guess
you know the corners corresponding
correspond to corners etcetera
but in case of gaussian it's hard to
tell whether
the you know in fact it's impossible to
tell whether this transform data
came from this version as the source or
this version as the source
right because in in in gaussians
you have these smooth ellipses and there
is this
rotational ambiguity of not being able
to
determine what the original shape was
whereas with these other distributions
they do not have this
you know smooth ellipse shape they have
these you know
the intuition to have is that you have
these corners right
and these corners can correspond to one
of these corners
these non gaussian distributions still
do have the ambiguity
that the the axis can be permuted
right you can construct you can
construct unmixing matrix
matrices that start from here
and map you back to the uh the the
on the unmixed versions where the axes
are permuted
because one corner can get mapped to a
different corner right
and you can also have ambiguity that the
axes are flipped in their in in their
sign
however though in in problems where
those ambiguities are tolerable
ica works very well which means for
example if you are applying ica to you
know audio source separation
once we unmix the unmix the mixed audio
clips
we recover the original audio clips but
the
the speaker one and speaker two
identities may have shifted
but that's okay because we never knew
what the original identities were
right in in case of icf once we once we
run ica and recover the unmixed versions
there is no guarantee that the first
column
of or or the identity of the first
source will always be the same
right there is there is ambiguity about
about what the original sources are and
there's also ambiguity that the sign is
flipped and in audio generally that's
okay too
the sign of your of your of your wav
file can
can can flip and you'll still get the
same audio
right so this gives us some intuition of
the ambiguity that
that arises only in gaussians right this
this spherical shape
is characteristic of the gaussian
distribution right in no other
distribution if you multiply the the uh
the if you multiply the the pdfs of
two independent distribution no other
will give you a contour map that is
spherical
the spherical shape comes only from a
gaussian so as long as
the um the
distribution of our sources is assumed
to be non-gaussian
we have some hope of recovering the the
original signal
yes there was a question
yeah so so the question is in practice
you know nobody actually speaks
according to a gaussian or laplace right
uh what's what's what's the uh uh you
know does it actually matter
uh it actually does matter a lot in fact
that's the only thing that matters
because even though your data may not be
may not be
distributed according to a gaussian what
i'm about to show in the next slide
here is that these these two clusters
that we see
are in fact uh so i just took the
waveforms on the two audio clips that i
uh that i played short a few a few
minutes ago
and just plotted a scatter plot of the
corresponding
um audio amplitudes from the two uh
sound clips
we see that the in the in the uh
separated version
even though they are not gaussian it is
still not spherical right so you there
is there is some amount of
you know you you can kind of see that
you know there is some elongation along
this axis
and there's some elongation on on this
axis and it's not perfectly spherical
so when we start with the mixed version
so this is basically
the scatter plot of the mixed audio
clips right
we see that the algorithm is able to
recover you know the
the the two independent components even
though the
the uh even though the data was not
actually
uh distributed according exactly
according to a laplace
or or or logistic
right so uh that's some intuition to to
uh show why non-gaussian assumption is
is important
[Music]
so with these two assumptions
so with these two assumptions we can now
formulate ica
and we need one final thing to take care
of
which is the the linearity assumption
so ah supposing we have a random
variable
let's assume it is uniformly distributed
between 0 and 1. it's a uniform random
distribution that lies between
0 and 1. so
x is uniform
let me take a different pen
uniform between zero and one
yeah this spins better
right and
the pr so which means x looks like this
0 and 1 and the pdf of x looks like this
so this is x this is p
of x so it has density
equal to 1 between zero and one and zero
everywhere else
right so this is just a uniform random
variable over zero and one
now what about two x
right what is let us consider y equals
two x what is p of y
so so what's what's what's p of so
when we when we when we do y equals two
x
now y will be distributed between 0 and
right it has density 0 outside this
region
what is p of y between 0 and 2
half right
this is half why is this half
right so exactly so we we the
probability distributions require
that the area under the pdf must
integrate to one
right so if we stretch the x axis we
have to shrink the y axis
by a corresponding amount and that is
because the area under the pdf must
integrate one
right now what happens in a higher
dimension if
x is you know in general x
in instead of one axis let's assume this
is some script x
right and instead of multiplying it by
one scalar
we do y equals say some
y equals w x where w is some matrix
now x is x is
is in rd
this is r d by d
and y is again in rd
right and we have
p or p of x to be some x to be some
value
so p of y
will be
what can we say about p of y p of y will
be
p of y is w x
right so let's assume this is the
density of
y and this is the density of x
is this correct is not correct right and
its
its not correct because of of the same
reason where p of y
had to be so p y of y had to be
p x of
two x times one over two
right so similarly here we need to
divided by the determinant of w
right this is this ah determinant of w
uh you you might have seen this from
your probability theory course
this is also called the jacobian
so jacobian when whenever you perform a
change of variable of your
random variable the density will be
transformed according to you know this
extra jacobian
okay this question
sorry this should be py
yeah because py is is uh oh sorry sorry
sorry
so
p y f y is p
p x of
x is y by 2 yeah y by 2 times
p times half that makes sense
and and what did i write here i think
here also i
this if ah similarly if p of y of y will
be
w inverse of y
w inverse of y times one order right
right so whenever whenever we
we ah transform a variable some linear
transform the density will get this
extra determinant factor
okay with just with with these
ah with these pieces in fact we are
ready to
finish pc ica so in ica
we define p of x
to be product
from j equals 1 to d
p s of w
j transpose x
times w
over here w
is the unmixing matrix
where w j
times some x
will get us back the jth
source right so w is the wj is the
unmixing matrix
you give it this mixed x multiply
multiplied each wj times x
will give us sj right so this is sj so
sj equals wsj times
x so wj times
x and we define the
the probability of x as in terms of p
of s and we make the assumption that p
of s
is distributed according to the logistic
distribution
so the logistic distribution is the
distribution whose cdf is the logistic
function right so
if you remember the logistic function is
is ah
p so the cdf
or cdf of x
is equal to 1 over 1 plus e to the minus
x
so this is the cdf of
logistic we can call this sigma of
x and so the pdf the probability density
of the logistic you know f of x
is the derivative of this that is
basically sigma of x
times one minus sigma of x where sigma
is the
is the sigmoid of the logistic function
right
and using this
so so this ah sigma sigmoid x times one
minus sigmoid x
will be p s of x so we assume that the
sources
are distributed according to the sigmoid
distribution which
gives us you know we can write the
l of w where the parameter here that we
are training is w
is sum over i equals one to n
sum over j equals 1 to d
log of the pdf which is
sigmoid of x times one minus
sigmoid so x i times one minus sigmoid
of
x i
right plus
log determinant of w
right so the parameter that we are
interested here is just w
previously the parameters that we were
trying to recover happen to be
the parameters of the you know of of the
probability
distribution itself for example we would
define the likelihood over mu
or sigma or some such thing like that
here the parameter that we are trying to
to learn is this the transformation w
that is going to take us back
into something that is distributed
according to sigmoid
and using the the uh the
linear transformation we we
we get this extra log determinant term
due to the extra
determinant that came due to the
jacobian
right and that's all there is to it
you take this objective take the
derivative
perform gradient ascend and run gradient
to send
until you converge right and the
corresponding update step so you take
the derivative of this
and you get uh the update step that
looks like this w
equals w plus alpha some learning rate
times 1 minus
2 g here g is just the
sigmoid 1 minus 2 sigmoid
of w 1 transpose x i
1 minus 2 sigmoid w 2
transpose x i
and so on times x i
transpose plus w
transpose inverse right so this is the
update rule
right and you can perform stochastic
gradient ascent and once this converges
take the converged w
multiply your x's with w
and you get s's and if you play these ss
you write it into a wave file and you
play these s's
they will be separated right it's almost
magical it works
and in your homework uh so here you have
the update rules for assuming
that pss were logistic and in your
homework you will do it you you know you
make a small
you type with a different distribution
you assume it's laplace distributed
and you know in in your homework you
have five different audio clips instead
of two audio clips
and you know run it till it converges
take the
resulting unmixing matrix the conversion
mixing matrix
and multiply your mixed audio clips
through it and you'll recover
a new audio clip and you play it and you
know they should they should sound
well separated and one final tip for
your homework
in the logistic distribution you will
encounter you know the absolute value of
x
and you have to differentiate it right
and the
you know what is d by d x of the
absolute value of x
yeah it is split so you know absolute
value of x looks like this
right so it is it has slope minus 1 when
it's negative
and slope plus 1 when it's positive so d
by dx of the absolute value of x
is just the sine of x right so you
you'll need that for your homework
uh you know you can probably would have
probably figured it out but in case you
are struggling the derivative of the
absolute value of x this is the sign of
x
and with this you can you know replace
replace the sigmoid pdf with the laplace
pdf
take the derivatives derive a different
update rule and
run it on the audio clips and you'll be
able to recover them and
yeah so that that that basically covers
pca and icf
any other questions if you have
questions you know walk up to walk up to
the
stage here happy to take questions